Come on
Come on egg gimme something good
Fuck you
Today I'm going to catch
So many goddamn dicks™
And you're coming along, babeh *wink*
You're coming along
[ dramatic music]
I'm gonna go on my morning run
But I'm gonna bring my phone with me
Just to catch Pokémon™
While I run
Yes that is as stupid as it sounds
But I wanted to give it a try
Let's go
Oh yeah
It's a beautiful day
To catch some Pokémons™
I don't know how this will work out
Me running at the same time
I realize how stupid it is
But I kinda love it
Alright let's do this
Alright this guy is really strong
Come on
Come one you piece of shit plant
Fuck yeah
Fuck you plant
Alright we ran past the pier
And...
We're gonna keep going
Cause there's a shit lot of  Pokémons™ here
Open your eyes
They're everywhere
Come here you fucking crab
There we go
I - I realized how much slower I run
But it's fucking worth it
[music playing] ♫ Live to win ♫
♫ 'Til you die ♫
♫ 'Til the light dies in your eyes ♫
People are looking at you like you're crazy
And I probably am
But this is
[heavy breathing]
I think this is the fastest way to catch a Pokémon™
[music playing] ♫ Live to win ♫
♫ Take it all♫
♫ Just keep fighting 'til you fall ♫
Okay
There's a
Gym right there
I think it's time we
Show it who's boss
I'm level 12
The gym is right there
Do you mind if I come in?
Come on you got the gym by yourself?
Fuck man
He's got the gym locked up
People have changed
People are barricading the gyms now
[laughs in sadness]
[sexy running]
Oh Pokémon™
Woah
Are you kidding me?
They['re] just keep appearing man
Alright eat some raspberry
Fuck you
This is painful
Man suck a fucking dick
Aw for fucks sake
Nooo
Goddammit
I guess you can't
Catch them all
I - I'm actually genuinely pissed about that
Don't talk to me right now
Someone has a Gyradus (Gyarados)
The fuck man?
How can you have a Gyrados (Gyarados) already?
What the fuck man?
Get a life
You nerd
Go inside
14 kilometers (8.7 miles) in
I'm back where we started
But I'm gonna keep going baby
Because I caught so many Pokémon™
And I'm gonna catch them all
Bitch
[boring walking]
I don't know where the fuck I am
I think it's time to go back
Ohhhhhh yeee yuhh
I feel pretty good
There's sweat and smudge all over the camera
Get the fuck out of my bath, Squirtle
Ooh those sexy legs
[ha ha]
[burp]
Oh sorry
I'm recording
I've caught so many Pokémons™
sooo many pokémons™
I ran
22 kilometers (13.7 miles)
Just to catch Pokémons™
I got a tan for the first time
Man Pokémon™ is changing people
OK so these are all the Pokémans™ I found
[dry heave]
This is ridiculous
Oh my god it keeps going guys
What are you doing on my dinner table, Drowzee?
This is the cutest Pokémon™
Of them all
[hoh hoh hoh]
[my]
[inhales]
you're cute :)
I can't capture though
You're useless
You're [still] useless
Alright now it's time to upgrade
And evolve my Pokémons™
First of all there's Drowzee
He's gonna be powerful as fuck
Go Drowzee
I imagine he get-
[distant screaming]
I imagine he gets swapped out by someone else
Hypnoooo
Woah would you look at that
I caught a Slowpoke for you by the way
[distant YAAAY]
nyeah [bites apple]
Can we just genocide the Drowzees already?
[distant gasping]
Aaand I think that's about it
Let's have a look at our team now
We got a really strong Hypno
Pidgeot, Hypno
Thank you
I'm trying to talk Pokémon™ here
jesus
That was a very successful hunt, but we're just beginning
Marzia, we're going to London today, right?
[yeee]
What are we gonna do in London?
[Wha-] Pokémon™ hunting
That's what we're gonna do
Let's go
Actually I gotta charge my battery
Oh my god
There's a giant as crab right there
Edgar do you see it?
There's a giant ass crab right there
How do we find it?
Marzia grab this phone
If you find any Pokémons™
damn it I clicked the wrong button
We're chasing a giant crab
You're moving
Yeah we're moving my-
Ahh
We're gonna drive to PJ's gym
PJ is so proud of his Blastoise
"Ooh I'm so proud at my Blastoise"
"Look at my Blastoise, Felix"
Well I'm gonna blast your Blastoise to space
What are you doing?
[demonic laughing]
You can't just park there-
I can and I'm doing it
6% battery
[beep beep]
Bro
Aw for fucks sake
[mumble about the driver]
OK Alright Alright
Are we here?
[beep]
Bro
Fuck you
[laughs]
This is illegal but it's OK cause it's Pokémon™
Battle Begins
Go Hypno
Piece of shit Blastoise
"Used Ice Beam"
More like Lame Beam
Hey nice filming you got there
YOU WIN!
And it's open
For business
For Pewdiepie
There you go
There you go, PJ
You got wreaked
This is my gym now
Was that stupid and unnecessary
And could anyone gotten hurt?
Absolutely
I'm getting really addicted to The Game
It's so much fun
It reminds me when I was playing MMOs a bit
When I was a kid
And I'm glad like friends like PJ is playing it as well
Cause... So I can wreck them
I'm working on the office
I'm gonna do a real like setup tour when it's done
Um
Getting all the cables sorted
And moved it into like this
Server locker?
That it's only so I can have like all my consoles and all that
Cause being a Youtuber, you're gonna have to deal with
Ey! Ey!
The fuck are you doing pooping on my carpet?
What's wrong with you?
Being a Youtuber, you have to deal with a lot of cables
It's bull - shit
It's dog shit
But yeah it looks pretty fucking good though
Got a reply from PJ
You bastard
You're finished
You hear me?
Ahh sweet victory
[evil laughing]
Alright that looks pretty fucking good
Look at that shit
Yeeyuh
I love my setup
That's all you get to see for now
Me and Marzia are going to London now
God
I really hate going to London
I can't believe we're going
Thank the Lord
For thee
Gotta go so fast
[travel music]
Thank you Burgees Hill Station
Appreciate it
Do you wanna try?
Let's just see your skills
So you gotta flick it harder
Ooh
Bullseye
Aw come on
No this is painful
Give it to me
Don't mind me
Just running to London
Oh my god
Hey Marzia, I found your Pokémon™
It's practically
[laughs]
[ye]
So Sam Strippin posted this yesterday
Everone in LA is playing on Santa Monica Pier
And a Wartortle appeared
And this happens
[hehehehehehe]
That's crazy
That's insane
This game is changing the world, man
I'm curious to see what Pokémons™ we can find in London
They sold it like there would be like different ones in different cities
Which I think would be really cool
I hope they will update it like that
Don't let me down, Nintendo™
OK we're here
Marzia has to do a video thing
I'm just coming along as a good boyfriend
Trust me I do not wanna be here
But Pokémons™ is making it OK
[happy music]
I found a real Pokémon™
Real Pokémon™
Yeah
[playing noises intensifies]
So many people see that you're playing and they approach you
And they wanna talk about the game
I think that's really cool
I never talked to so many strangers just cause I'm playing a game
Y'know?
In person at least
I think it's really cool
It's real interesting
Marzia you're done with your thing
We're gonna go back to Brighton right away
yeeeeeeeeeah
I'm so tired actually
That run really killed me this morning
I really like the game, but I think it could be so much more
Imagine if you could challenge people when you see them on the street
I think - I think the game could be so much more
Right now it's kind of buggy
I still really enjoy it
I gotta end this part here
Let me know if you wanna do Part 3
I'm really enjoying this game
I hope you Bros are enjoying the episode
And as always, stay awesome Bros